thank you guys so much for doing this i
absolutely loved this movie it's
brilliant it
had me cackling and crying in equal
measure so
thanks my wife was in the other room she
was like what are you laughing at it was
like there's a furby
and he's raising the dark harvest
our proudest moment you know with
parents and kids there's sometimes a
disconnect
in terms of what they feel like they
should be doing or
or if they kind of even understand each
other
um and you know this has been going on
for ages
and it's something that i think is
immensely relatable so i kind of wanted
to start off just by asking each of you
you know when you first knew you wanted
to be an artist and then how
your family or or you know friends
reacted when
when you told them i sort of decided
when i was 14 i was like i'm gonna
i read about that tom morello from rage
against machine
played the guitar eight hours a day and
i was like well i'm gonna draw
for 12 hours a day and my parents were
like what are you
doing and my dad was very much like
let's
think great cool just think about real
estate bud
um so he was like he was like really
trying to pull me
into that um but ultimately i just they
just sort of like
really relented um because i was such a
lunatic and they're like well he clearly
likes this stuff i don't know but it was
there was always like tension about it
um and so
so that it is sort of like that part of
the movie does come from my real life
because it like
i think it took a long time for me to
appreciate that he wasn't just like a
villain that he was like oh he's
actually has my best interest at heart
he's not just saying that to be a jerk
and then it you know i think it took him
a while to sort of understand that like
oh i'm not
just sort of that i'm my own person and
not just sort of like i think he liked
it a lot when everyone were
babies because it was like very simple
you know he's like oh yeah you know i
tickle them and they laugh and that's
it's all very simple and now they're
like
mad at me for some reason and i can
dress them like any occupation i choose
yeah exactly he's a little fireman today
i always used to draw and make
weird puppets and things uh a sense as
far as i can remember and i i do
remember one thanksgiving
i made a very elaborate turkey puppet
that i brought to the dinner table and
when my grandparents brought the turkey
to the table i went
uncle larry uh and my grandfather said
that's a good bit yeah he said honestly
and i remember my mom said like this is
just who he is
and i thought to myself yeah this is who
i am
my parents are both musicians and my
father
ran a dance company for a really long
time
and when they s
they saw that i was artistically
inclined
i think they were deeply worried
when i told my mom that chris and i
wanted to move to los
angeles and try to make it in the
animation biz
she said oh no honey
uh and then you had cancer or something
yeah it was just like
oh we tried so hard to keep you from
falling into the same
traps that we fell into uh
and and i think at some point later
after we moved here my dad pulled me
aside
and was like son i'm afraid
that you're an artist and
there's nothing you can do about it
[Laughter]
and that's advice that i tell people
sometimes if they're young and they
aren't considering a career
i tell them that i'm very sorry but they
don't really have a choice
they're going to be stuck doing this so
they better start getting good at it
that's perfect well that you know that's
one of the things that i love about the
film because it is
it's kind of universal in that way
because you know i think sometimes
parents think they're creating a mini
version of themselves and when their
child takes a different path they feel
like
they don't even know them anymore but
the film does a great job of really
bridging that gap of like if you look if
you
work to understand one another you can
find more commonalities than
than you may assume are there because of
the differences
that is true but kind of just to go back
what was the earliest
idea that became the mitchells versus
the machines
um yeah it sort of it sort of came for
me
where um i was sort of i had this
opportunity and sony was like hey do you
want to pitch something and i was like
yes do you have any ideas and i was like
i've got
a zillion ideas that i had no ideas um
so i i basically um tried to
quickly write a bunch it's sort of
indicative of the whole process where
it's like oh god
i have to do all this stuff um and and
sort of like making promises that i
couldn't quite cache
yet um but um but
i i stumbled upon something that i was
really excited about
um because i love really personal and
unique
movies um and it seemed like oh i could
tell a
i could tell a really personal sort of
subtle specific family story
if i can wrap it up in some sort of
genre
you know uh package um and and as a kid
i love the robots
um and i still do and as an adult i'm
sort of think a lot about how
you know we live in a world where robots
and
uh you know ai can do some of the same
things we can do so what is the thing
that's like worth
worth saving about humanity what's the
thing that's like really important about
humanity
um and it sort of ends up being sort of
our relationships um which
dovetailed nicely into this sort of
family story i wanted to tell because i
i really
i just think the more specific you can
be about families the more
it hits people and the more oddly
universal it is
um so i sort of basically uh modeled it
after my own insane family um and it's
like the dad
looks exactly like my dad um and he's
like you gave me some extra hair
thank you um but uh but so so yeah
that's that's sort of what the initial
nucleus of
well then phil and chris at one point
did you come in because i know
the film was announced i think right
before spider-verse came out
um which i'm sure put even more pressure
on this project to be that much greater
um it was pretty early on uh mike had
put together
uh and his team had put together a
really funny
animatic um really early and it was all
you know mike's voices for all the parts
um
and uh but you could tell even then
that it was it had like a really
distinct voice
uh and vision and that it was really
funny and really emotional and those are
two things are
hard to find stories that do both of
that
uh and so um they asked us we wanted to
come aboard and and and help mike um
make it the movie the best it could be
and we thought it was an amazing
opportunity to
to help a filmmaker whose vision we
really believed in so
we just jumped at the chance and then
two and a half years later we uh
uh we've been you're still jumping just
a little more tired
well that emotion i think is one of the
things that sets it apart and
you know you look at the animation
medium and a lot of animated films that
come out
are family comedies and it's a family
movie there's a misunderstanding
they have to work together and at the
end there's a cathartic emotional scene
what i really loved about this film is
that it's almost as if the emotional
scenes are the set pieces they come
kind of almost every 20 minutes or so
they hit really hard
they're shot really beautifully i think
you know even just the cinematography of
them is
is like telling the audience this is not
your pee break this is not your time to
like you know walk away
like this is something to pay attention
to and you really get wrapped up in the
emotion
and i was wondering if you guys could
talk about maybe kind of positioning
those
if those set pieces were always kind of
there i keep calling them set pieces
but they do feel like that they feel
like these foundational pieces
on which the entire film is built and if
they don't work then the film doesn't
work
no totally i think it at certain points
there were
there were some moments where i was like
and it was like in this screening
if the audience leaves during this
emotional scene if the audience goes to
the bathroom during this emotional scene
we're
dead so i mean it really came from
because we always had that emotional
spine there
and it was really just sort of plussing
those moments and massaging them
you know in some of the ways you're
talking about with the cinematography
and with the
you know storytelling to to like how can
you
and it really it was often just really
slowing down
um and and chris and phil were great at
helping with that
um you know because because sort of it's
like
you know you know it's p you can get it
like worked into a
worked into a for you know frazzled
because you're like oh the movie has to
be 90 minutes uh
and you get all freaked out and they're
like no no just let these moments play
like this is this is important if these
aren't playing the movie doesn't play so
um so they were always there and we just
over the course of the years we're just
like
tightening them and and sort of often
times like lengthening them
to make to make to tell the audience
that this is
the these these characters emotions
matter
and their stories matter and it's not
and and it's sort of like this isn't a
um we're not like filling off the check
we're not like checking off the story
boxes
we actually care about these characters
um sort of reuniting and stuff
yeah we want you to be immersed in those
moments and what that requires is enough
real estate for the animators to
um show us what people are thinking
before and
after they say something or maybe
there's no dialogue and we're just
watching
rick you know take in these
videos and if there's not enough time
you know and if you don't
um you know what i love about that first
moment
rick is looking at videos of katie his
daughter as
a young girl and he
it's really dark you know it's like a
lit
it's lit really dark um and
the mark mothers bob's music is really
beautiful there
and has a really nice warm melody it
just
has it just the movie's taking that
stuff seriously
and and it's kind of refreshing because
it doesn't take everything seriously
so it might surprise you well it's
incredibly silly but
it's silly again if those pieces don't
work the whole film
doesn't work but those pieces really
ground the emotions of the characters
and you're not only it's not
a film that's just immersing you in the
protagonist and katie and like ah her
dad is awful and then at the end you're
like oh no i like the dad
like you really understand both points
of view throughout the entire film
and because we have those those kind of
foundational
um signposts you know we can give
rick like really skinny legs and a
really weird
waist and a torso that sort of hangs
over it like a muffin
and and and you still care because
you know we treat him like a human being
well i was wondering if you guys could
talk about um just how you went about
visualizing the story again
you know spider-verse i know was a lot
of banging your heads against a wall
until you really broke ground
that film is groundbreaking uh i'm sure
sets
uh you know a really high bar to hit um
not to say this movie looks like
spider-verse but it does feel
like it's visually being ambitious it's
not just sticking to what an animated
film is supposed to look like yeah it
has its own aesthetic that really
matches what
mike wanted the thing to look like and
luckily we had already broken the
pipeline
at imageworks and built a bunch of
i say we built as though we were coding
software
the team of spiderverse that was very
talented
had built a lot of new tools that uh
that could be adapted and expanded
and changed around to do things that had
never been done
and to make this film look as unique and
unique in its way as spider-verse looked
in its own way
yeah like one one example is that like
in spider-verse
they have this really cool effect where
with the lighting
looks is like looks like those comic
book dots they're called like bend a
dots or whatever and then they sort of
took that tool
and like bent it the other way and sort
of used
watercolor brushes um that like our team
provided
so so basically it was like you were
seeing even in the lighting
really subtly you can't really tell when
you watch the movie but there's just
like overall
hopefully it sort of hits you as this
thing that's made by a person
so that the like humanity of the family
is like reflected on every frame
ideally there's crew members that are
you know cross-pollinating between the
two pictures so
you know michael asker vfx soup on on
mitchell's worked on spider-verse and
now
he's taking all of the smart things
that they figured out on mitchell's and
applying it to spider-verse 2.
mike lasker was really funny it was it
was almost like spider-verse like
broke him because like when we when we
met with him the first time
he was so like beaked up he was like
yeah what do you got
and then we're like we were used to like
everyone started being like why do you
want to make it look different he's like
how could we make it look more different
i was like whoa
um but it was so fun because he was
excited and we were excited so
as soon as we started throwing himself
he's like let's do 14 versions and i was
like
i would love it if you did 14 um so he
was he was really great
was there any sequence in particular
that was like oh this might break us or
like this one is
we're having a really hard time getting
this one right in terms of the
visualization of it
for me at least the hardest thing was
just finding that
first initial look of picture um
because like i feel like once we found
the look of picture
i wouldn't say it was easy but like all
of the scenes
more or less fell in place and and the
big
stumbling block was like what exactly
does the movie look like
um and and it took all these iterations
and there are versions of the movie that
look
straight up insane just like you know
like
it looks like a horrible video game or
something
and we we just sort of had to keep um
sort of keep pushing it and stuff um to
to make it look different and
i would do this test where i would take
like three recent animated movies
and like i had them on little pieces of
paper and i would hold them next to the
screen
and i was like it doesn't quite look
different enough yet
really
[Laughter]
and then and it was cool and it was like
awesome with with chris and phil because
you know i we can say that and say we
wanted to look more different and we
wanted to
reflect humanity in every frame you know
and the studio's like yes
get out of here kid but it was cool to
have
chris and phil to be able to be like no
do what this
lunatic is saying and sort of and also
pushed us to
um push us to go further too because we
we were like at one point like
we pushed this pretty far and then
they're like can you make it look more
like the stuff you guys love which was
like the best night we ever got
see the one thing i remember
specifically that was really hard to get
right
in this was the hair on the characters
yeah
that was the one of the things like even
when you sort of like
landed on the look and the watercolor
feel and the environments and how it
integrated with the characters and the
color lines on everybody and the
hand-drawn
details it was that how do you do
hair that's simulated like regular hair
so it flops around the way
hair especially a messy haired character
like katie
and have it feel as stylized as
everything else and when you're painting
with watercolor you're not painting
every hair you're
painting these broad swaths with a
couple of little detail lines in it but
then
if you do that just that it ends up
looking like the hair is big
plastic or metal or something or like
stiff and so you had to like
how does it have the movement of hair
and the feeling of hair but is
as stylized as the rest of the movie
that i remember sort of like the last
thing that we kind of like okay this
looks good
that was one where we like like the they
were like this is the most expensive
like our
rick's hair they're like this is the
most expensive head of hair
in sony image works history we hope
you're happy we made
if you tell us it was the second most
expensive we'd say well what can we do
we make it the most expensive yeah how
significantly you said just two and a
half years how significantly did the
story itself change
uh during that time or did it kind of
lock into place pretty early
the pillars of the story are exactly the
same and the characters
are exactly the same and the specifics
of the story
have changed a lot there was always a
giant furby if i'm not mistaken that's
true
as long as it's a giant furby there's
always like we can't change this
well actually briefly we had to take it
out because they were like
the producers like they're never going
to go for this so we had to
tickle me melmo who is the eye patched
elmo like from
mad max that's right but anyway
um but uh but you know a lot of the
specifics and a lot some of the like
minor character drives and and a lot of
the specifics of the scenes
uh are are very different from how they
started
but but like the spirit of the story is
the same it went from a
movie about people fighting to a movie
about people getting along
and so the middle of the movie has a lot
of
sort of subtle little accomplishments
and um we would say like these this
family needs to put points on the board
because we've established the problem we
established what's what's not right and
now we
want to watch them try to make it right
even if they fall short
um because i think you got a little
tired
in in older versions where they just you
know
you spend a lot of time arguing with
your family in real life
it's nice to go to the movies and sort
of model what it looks like when you
don't fight with them
yeah and it was really tricky to get it
so that
the family was having positive
accomplishments and and
everyone was trying but that it wasn't
fully 100 clicking in which case the
movie would be over
in that they uh they uh
and so having them still have something
to to strive for
was a was a tricky balance but but uh
mike and jeff and the whole team were
really
amazing at figuring a way to navigate
through that
well it was also really pleasantly
surprised by the film's approach to
technology
and specifically the villain i mean you
don't necessarily
plan on empathizing with a cell phone um
i guess
i guess getting olivia coleman helps a
little bit
but again that speech and i i've been
seeing this more and more recently
um but you think about villains like
killmonger or
magneto where it's like i don't agree
with their methods but i can understand
where they're coming from
um but also just with the technology
with you know
this film isn't like everyone stop
looking at your phones all the time
that's what's wrong with the world
again you know it's through katie's
point of view in katie's eyes this is
how she communicates
and i was just kind of wondering how you
guys approach that technological aspect
and
and the villain itself um who falls in a
couple bar
at the end um i that that was a really
that was a really tricky balance because
you know like those villains
if your villain doesn't have a
compelling reason
to do the things they're doing the movie
doesn't work
or the movie feels like you know you
feel like a dummy whenever the villain's
on because at
certain points in the movie the audience
was like wrap it up
um whenever powell would come on you
know um
and i think that i think that it really
took sort of
having pal making really good points you
know and sort of
and giving the positive case for
technology which
100 exists um you know sort of like cell
phones help us they connect us
you know they're not the problem people
who use
the cell phones you know uh incorrectly
are the problem
um you know the technology is just a
tool and humanity are the people who are
not using it well
um so that was sort of her point and
also the another thing that we learned
is just like
just unless it's unless your story is
about a relationship
i feel like the audience really loses
steam
um and when we sort of when we made the
sort of realization to
make it a relationship between mark and
powell that mark
threw away pal and powell was resentful
and saw that as an example of all the
bad things that humans do
that's finally when that like those
scenes made sense
because you could kind of tie it to the
family you know leaving people behind
and that sort of thing
um so so it was this balance of of
trying to give the positive case for
technology as well as
the dangers and it does help having
oscar winner olivia coleman do the lines
yes doesn't got a lot better crunchy
international treasure she she's so good
and she's also so funny i mean i always
wear
like she's in hot fuzz just playing a
really silly character and hot fuzz
so uh it's always nice to see her stress
those comedic jobs again
well she can she can do both so well
it's like if
her her scary reads are like spine
chilling
and her funny reads are like the
funniest lines you've ever heard
so speaking of technology where did the
furby come from
how did the furby evolve because i'd
seen like the snippet in the trailer but
just watching that entire sequence
in within the context of the film i i
was laughing my head off the entire time
i'm very glad because in our in our
first
screening we had that scene and and
i would say 50 of the audience was
really into it and then there were a
couple moms that were like we are
leaving
um but um but it was uh it was basically
like
you know we were trying to come up with
something that was like we're always
trying to like
come up with specifics um and one of my
friends had showed me a picture of what
happens when you take the face off of a
furby and it was the scariest thing i've
ever seen in my life
and we tried to do that in the movie and
it was too horrifying
um so um so we had to pull back from
that but then there was all this drama
about like
will we be able to get it um and we were
finally able to sort of like
like hey this this could be good for
it's good for furby it's good for us
it's great for everybody um
i think uncut gems helped us i think so
sure why not it did brought it into the
lexicon it sort of
revitalized furbys when it came out
we're like uh oh they got there first
i think it's all right there's room for
both yeah
it just put it back in the meme culture
uh zeitgeist there which fits right in
line with the film i think
yeah which is something i really like
though because you know it's easy to
decry
you know memes and and kids on tick tock
and stuff but again
the film is saying this is how katie
communicates you know
it's bridging a gap of understanding
between her and her father and i love
that that's visualized in the film
um with various memes uh was it hard to
kind of find that balance of like are we
doing too much
are there too many like meme pop-ups
throughout here
yeah i at one point i showed it to my
nephew who was 14
and he's like he's like the glass is
lowering
the old vine thing that sucks man that's
not cool anymore and i was like
feverishly writing like okay um like my
unpaid 14 year old
you know uh focus test like okay what
what what memes do you like um
but ultimately it was like we had to
just go with things that were more
universal
i think we got into trouble when it was
like a really specific meme
from like right now because it would
immediately be dated when you'd see it
but you know it's like a screaming
monkey kind of everybody likes the
screaming i think
if it's only funny if you know the memes
then it's not good enough
yes it has to be something that if you
don't know what this is
then and it works for the story and what
the character is doing than than we're
golden
yeah but i think that like it was
important to you know
we were saying that katie's a filmmaker
and she's using these tools
to make her movies and share them with a
community
of like-minded people and there's no way
you want to say that
that's a bad thing and we should stop
doing that it's a tool for creativity
and
communication and uh and it's exciting
that you can do that and at the end
you know it's important that you see the
families literally
communicating over uh like a zoom-like
program uh with each other using
technology in a healthy
and positive way so it certainly
we didn't want to make it like cell
phones are evil
like the most banal and trite thing you
could say
yeah that that's what i really
appreciated about the home is it didn't
really take any of the obvious routes
um that you might expect to film like
this to take i wanted to talk about the
ending
um which not only you know how do you
dispose of the villain throw in a glass
water
um but that that moment you just
described with the zoom call i was
wondering how you guys how early you
guys hit upon
the right note uh you know for the end
of the film
and uh how that kind of evolved maybe
evolved
that's the little sequence came and went
right it kept shaking out of the movie
and we were worried about
length um and
i just remember when we put that in the
scores
shot up like crazy if i'm not mistaken
yeah well i think i think people you
know
wanted to make sure that the family
that whatever bond that they had wasn't
over you know like like they want to
make sure that all these wins that they
got in the movie aren't just like well
now katie's off to college all progress
is lost
you know and i think that like it was
feeling like without
something like that um uh which could
be feel you know like maybe too much or
something but with it we found that
without that
without like seeing the family go on a
road trip together at the very end
that it felt like um that it was just a
little bit unsatisfying because you
the audience wanted to see katie
regarded as a hero by her peers and they
wanted to see
you know the family having made these
strides and we we found that when
we took it out people were like
what happened they were they were all um
upset
that's fair was it difficult to find how
to dispose of the villain
uh to dispose of the antagonist um
i don't think that was honestly very
early
and we had to we had to
we had to update it because in between
the time we started the movie and in
between then we ended the movie
cellphones became waterproof
so and we got as we started getting this
note like cell phones are waterproof fu
this movie sucks um so we're like all
right we'll put a crack in it uh is that
okay are you guys good with that
um and that that seemed to work that's
funny
i feel like there was a chapter where we
like she was hunting for a bag of
rice and couldn't find it that was going
to be the end tag is like
done and then like a spotlight comes
down on a piece a cup of rice and then
like you see a robot hand
done drop it in did you guys put that
into putting that together or
was that uh we never actually i think we
boarded it but it was just
at a certain point it was like the
ending was already like 25 minutes long
or something
well and it's in that ending as well
that you know it's conv
there are there are some hints
throughout the film but it's confirmed
that katie is part of the lgbtq
community
and i wonder if you guys could talk
about that because it's i really love
that it's not a plot point
it's not a point of contention it's just
a thing that exists as
happens in everyday life we just like
wanted to
sort of like reflect in the whole movie
just like real people and real families
that we love
you know um and we also have a lot of
uh crew members that are lgbtq plus and
like when this came up
we had sort of like ran it by them and
they were like go do it
more you know they were so excited um
that it got us excited we're like oh
this seems great
um and but then at the same time the the
story isn't about
you know coming out or sexuality or
anything like that it's just about how
to deal with your family and
in talking with them it sort of seemed
like oh that is a better way to go
where it's like you know just like her
eyes are brown
you know she happens to like girls um
and you know if it's normal in real life
why shouldn't it be normal on animation
yeah yeah and no big whoop
yeah right and i think we did versions
of the movie where it like
really tried to steer into that more
and it just didn't feel right felt
inorganic
yeah and and the thing that's lovely
about it
is you know no you know
it's not an issue for their family their
issue is about like
you know the you know the differences
in generations and essentially like you
know
rick saying like why do kids leave the
house
i don't like this and then not also not
understanding her
art and it's not about uh anything about
you know and you don't really want to
model that right right yeah really want
to tell a story
for especially that you know a lot of
the children are going to watch where
you even give people the idea that it
might
not be okay you know or that someone in
your family might not go for this
that was that was really on our minds
too i think
i thought that was really well done um
and really appreciate that point as well
um also really blown away by the voice
cast on the film
um all around i was wondering if you
guys could talk about putting that
together
i made a mistake you know me and jeff
when we were writing the movie
jeff rowe co-writer and co-director who
was a genius um
uh because we sort of weren't writing it
towards voices we were just sort of like
writing
like oh this is kind of like my dad or
something but and we sort of
realized that when we did get people
like danny mcbride and abby jacobson and
my rudolph it was like
so electrifying to have these people
bring all of their
creativity into it um and it also made
the characters easier to write you were
like oh
i know kind of the fun areas that abby
jacobson plays with or whatever the
character is and
and so and it also like in in in
engaging them you know they'll say
something really funny in a voice record
and we'll be like oh we should like
write towards that
um because it was such a good bit um and
they're all like
you know abby and danny are like writers
and directors and stuff so it's like
they also know how to sort of shape
scenes and stuff like so they
they like know the moves and and you
know they don't like go
insane with improv but they sort of keep
it
sort of like towards the point of the
scene um so it was like
wonderful to bring all them in because
they they really brought the movie
up exponentially when we got their
voices in i really appreciated back
bennett and fred armisen that's
they're great you can tell they like
each other
yeah uh i i wrote
in my notes in all caps here mark mother
spa uh i think his score
is incredible in this film i i've loved
his his work in hollywood films phil and
chris and and just really
thought this one i think this is one of
his best scores uh i was wondering if
you guys could
could talk about working with him on
here well it really is
beautiful and it does all the things
that mark does really well which is
um sweet melodies
really unusual sounds and then weird
computer beepy boopy
stuff that you've never heard before uh
bringing that sort of like weird
like cynthia tron element onto a very
like
analog earthy homemade score
uh and it sort of takes all of his
superpowers and then
and then i think he just did a really
beautiful job
mark is as known for his
you know quirky palette and arrangements
but
um the surprising thing is that his
melodies are so memorable
and and we've listened to a lot of
composers and i don't know if anyone
writes melodies as beautiful as marx or
as memorable
and then you go oh right he's like a
grammy-winning songwriter
he's in the rock and roll hall of fame
for writing memorable
songs sorry my dog is barking at people
uh outside of the room it happens um
yeah it's it's a tremendous score um you
know i also wanted to ask i mean
obviously this film was supposed to come
out last year
it was supposed to hit theaters uh it's
now going to netflix
what was that experience for you guys of
of finding out
the film would be switching to netflix
and changing titles do you have a
preference on the title
they said like hey they're the you know
they're moving moving to netflix and
they're
bringing they want the original title
back and i was like why am i wearing a
netflix shirt right now this is the best
day of my life um uh so it was that was
cool and i think it was sort of like a
signal
too that netflix was like really game
to sort of um engage with the things
that we
really loved about the movie you know
that that it's
that it's that it is original and sort
of like leaning into that which was
really cool
and also just in general it's it's
really nice
to be able to say to anyone like hey you
could see this movie
on friday go see it and and they're not
worried about
you know they're they're not worried
about anything and they're they're like
able to watch it safely and as soon as
possible
because um you know one thing we talked
about is like even though
like hopefully this is hitting people
great right now but
you know that who knows what what i
would play in four months five six seven
eight
nine months so um we're glad to get it
out as soon as possible because it's
about technology
right super resonant for this moment
hopefully
it's uh um universal for all time but
it's a special one coming out of
an apocalyptic type event where
uh you know technology was was something
that we
was both uh a you know a savior and
uh and a crutch and
a villain i'm happy that
you know people the world over can see
it i'm still hoping out holding out a
little bit of hope that
netflix will somehow put in theaters
because i'd love to see this on a big
screen
uh at some point because i i just think
it's beautiful
it's really it's it's the artist did a
lot of great work and i do
sort of hope that it certain points we
someone could watch it on a big screen
because it's
it was made for that and it's yeah and
it's they just put a lot of love into
each
frame but i like to uh sit very close
to the television
very good for your eyes yep and pro tip
if you
just kind of stick your thumb out there
and imagine that that's like
another person in the theater five rows
ahead
kind of works just put a podcast on low
so you can mimic people talking during
the movie
yeah guys i'm trying to watch the film
i believe the cough is still in the film
is there a cough in this one okay there
is that is one of my favorite gags in
all of cinema
what's funny is that like especially for
a film that's really
mostly going to be playing in people's
homes it's extra weird
there's someone in your house
[Music]
that's not someone in your house that's
that's chris miller's cough
from 22 jump street that's right
i love that uh you know i do also feel
like the film is built to last so i i
appreciate the the fact that i can just
throw it on uh you know anytime now and
i
it does feel like a film that's going to
be made
it's going to be like a feel-good movie
for people um
because i and it's got a lot of
re-watchability to it
and i will say as someone who loved the
movie and loved the characters
are there any plans for a sequel i'm
okay if there's not
um but do you guys have ideas for any
follow-ups
i'll say sony is really excited for a
sequel we're all pretty tired right now
yeah yeah
if you're not working on anything else
if you pause the movie at a certain
point
you could read all of katie's pitches
for the sequel
which are okay totally bizarre and
insane
so look out for those and also if
there's a fan campaign to make one of
them maybe they'll make that one i don't
know
really i like that like maybe the
reporter can make
a bracket yeah
yeah uh i am interested in that i want
to thank you guys so much for
taking time to to talk to me about this
wonderful movie and i want to thank you
guys for making it
i i really appreciate it and uh i love
this movie and i hope everybody watches
it
hey thank you this is my
favorite interview of all time